Let's look at the path planning problem as a search problem.
If you took my AI online class, you know what this is all about,
but I want to make sure that everybody can understand what I'm talking about.
Let's start with a little grid world of size 6 x 5
where our start location is in the top left corner, our goal in the bottom right corner.
I block off a few cells so there is still a safe path to the goal.
This could be a search through a city graph, through a parking lot,
or through a maze of streets for a mobile robot.
Just for simplicity, in this example let's assume the robot is given 4 actions.
It can go up, down, left, or right.
Also for simplicity, let's assume every action succeeds with absolute certainty.
We don't model uncertainty in this example.
The path planning or search problem is to find the shortest sequence of actions
that leads our robot from the start state to the goal state.
Just to check, tell me how many you think these are.
How many action are required to go from start to goal?